[Music]
just a few years ago blizzard was one of
the most beloved companies in gaming
they were the masterminds who made one
of the biggest games of all time they
basically created esports as we know it
and then they tried to change what it
meant to be an esports pro forever
[Applause]
but as poor decision after poor decision
began to unravel the community's trust
in their favorite developer the ugly
truth became obvious it is a company
that is so far out of touch and so
corrupt that it's gross because there
were signs things were a little bit
weird right we were being told
everything was going great it is not fun
it is not skill it is [ __ ] [ __ ]
the agency alleges that male employees
play video games during the work day
while delegating responsibilities to
female employees engage in sexual banter
and joke openly about rape among other
things all of this is awful to hear
about and it's completely normal to feel
hurt and betrayed and disgusted
especially from a company like blizzard
that many people still idolized and
aspired to the blizzard we all knew and
loved
died a long time ago
hey folks before we get to the video i
just want to remind you all to please
sub to the channel and turn on
notifications if you haven't done it yet
because it really does help
okay so back in the day blizzard was on
top of the world an entire generation of
gamers grew up playing warcraft diablo
and starcraft every new release wasn't
just a hit it was a revolutionary new
approach to a genre blizzard's name on
any game was basically ironclad proof of
quality they always had their reputation
too where it was like we'll release it
when it's ready and it was kind of a
joke in the gaming community right
because like it's like oh it's delayed
into lane delayed but you knew when it
came out it was going to be really good
so it was it was worth it you know all
over the world blizzard's games were
changing the industry starcraft became a
huge hit in korea leading to the
development of a massive esports scene
that eventually went global the team was
trying to create
the most serious intense strategy game
they possibly could and there was no
sort of expectations and then i think
blizzard became very aware oh
this is what this could be and years
later with the launch of the overwatch
league it seemed like a career in
esports wasn't just possible it was
basically like landing a spot on a
professional sports team these guys are
getting paid to do this the league
minimum is 50 grand a year yes and how
high does it go potentially um so there
currently isn't a salary cap so the
scale is as good as and is to me demand
of the players um so the reality is i
don't see these guys any different um
and these players any different than a
lebron james a stephen curry they are
the elite of the elite at what they do
globally for years no one could compete
with blizzard their games had legions of
adoring fans all over the world a ton of
exciting new projects were coming down
the pipe and for many of blizzard's
employees working for them was a literal
childhood dream come true and all of a
sudden this email pops up and it's from
blizzartana and i'm like
and it was a recruiter here and he said
would you be interested in taking our
tests for blizzard entertainment i was
like uh yeah it's been my dream job
since i was 12 years old
but it turns out that behind the scenes
that dream was more of a nightmare and
the cracks in the facade began to show a
lot earlier than many of us realized in
2008 blizzard merged with activision
creating a new entity known as
activision blizzard but it wasn't just
the company's name that changed see even
while blizzard were releasing some of
their biggest most beloved games it
seemed like they were getting further
and further away from their founding
principles games for gamers by gamers
where every voice mattered i love what
you guys done with littlecrest i love
the fact that you have a lot of very
strong female characters however i was
wondering if we could have some that
don't look like they've stepped out of
victoria's secrets catalog
[Applause]
wait wait
which catalog would you like them to
step out of
blizzard was slowly but surely losing
their connection to the people they made
their games for and tone-deaf decisions
followed one after another it is a
company that is so far out of touch and
so corrupt that it's gross and then they
merged with activision to form
activision blizzard and it was like the
power rangers coming together to make a
megazord of pure filth it'd be like
combining dog [ __ ] and horse [ __ ] and
then creating the ultimate pile of [ __ ]
which is activision blizzard and
blizzard's leadership was also ignoring
the community's pleas for the sorts of
games they actually wanted to play or
for the things they wanted to see in
those games
uh have you ever thought about adding
servers for previous expansions as they
were then
no
and
and by the way you don't want to that to
do that either you think you do but you
don't
miss pandaria bled subscriber so hard
that it was still shocking even after
cataclysm got people used to the idea
while it only lost a few hundred
thousand in the first quarter
second quarter of this expansion
really it led to a fall of 1.3 million
subscribers the game's largest yet of
course no game developer is safe from
criticism but it seemed like the folks
over at blizzard thought they were
beyond reproach as if they'd been told
they could do no wrong for so long they
actually started to believe it and if
you need any proof of that look no
further than the disaster that was the
diablo immortal announcement
diablo
immortal we are so excited about this
game
if you want to know more we'll be back
here on the mythic stage in just a few
minutes
for those of you who are here at
blizzcon
thank you
we are going to have
sorry
is there any plans to make this playable
on pc or is this just strictly mobile
forever
uh are there any uh yeah
this the current plan is to be on mobile
both android and ios uh we don't have
any plans at the moment to do a pc
do you guys not have phones yeah you
guys all haven't identified
you can play your tablet too
shocking absolutely no one but blizzard
fans of a franchise that redefined pc
action rpgs weren't exactly interested
in a mobile game the whole thing felt
like a slap in the face
hey uh just was wondering is this uh an
out of season april fool's joke
i mean you've got to know you [ __ ] up
when people at your own convention are
booing you
right
but things were about to get a lot worse
from blizzard
back in 2016 a few years before the
diablo immortal debacle blizzard
announced its boldest undertaking yet a
multi-million dollar professional
esports league for one of its most
popular titles overwatch fans could
attend matches live in person or watch
them on twitch when the league finally
got underway in 2018 blizzard was
selling out their studio games bringing
in big-name talent from all over esports
and the people loved it it looked like
blizzard did it again but behind the
scenes things had already started to go
sideways in february 2019 blizzard
announced their record-breaking fourth
quarter earnings and in a shocking twist
a wave of mass layoffs to go along with
those earnings because there were signs
things were a little bit weird right
where at the end of the first season we
had blown all of our that we knew of all
of our viewership metrics out of the
water um we were being told everything
was going great uh and then at the end
of the year they were like and how would
you like a pay cut too and or like well
that's a little bit strange and it
seemed like the same thing was happening
over on twitch's end i was not able to
speak publicly about owl while i worked
at twitch for obvious reasons but you
better believe that i was the guy in
every [ __ ] meeting going this is
stupid and you're all stupid it it did
not feel good
i'll tell you why it didn't feel good
because that league cost a lot of
[ __ ] money
and a year later 11 of my [ __ ] staff
was laid off
then in 2020 blizzard inked a three-year
deal with youtube tanking the league's
viewership numbers in the process dude
there's a there's also a big change that
the os league just gonna die completely
i guess that's a big change
yeah
and when i mean that i mean 50k viewers
the people that made that deal didn't
understand the nuance of where a game
lives as far as where people prefer to
consume that game's content and while i
think that in an ideal world overwatch
could have certainly grown on youtube
and it has grown on youtube you know it
took time but at the moment that was a
step back for sure meanwhile the game
itself was increasingly plagued by
bizarre balance issues setting many of
its most prolific pros into retirement
or seeking opportunities elsewhere well
goats is dead
um and now it's just double sniper and
that's going to be terrible or oh now
everybody's just going to play mccree
and at a certain point i'm like
what the hell do you people want so in
other words you don't want them to eat
all the olds in the game like diva no
yeah makes sense
there are these moments of regret that
you have as
a game developer
and perhaps eating everybody's ult is
one of those
maybe this is gonna be a hot take i
think this [ __ ] is the worst thing
to happen to overwatch this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] up it is not fun it is not skill
it is [ __ ] [ __ ]
it is dog it is dog [ __ ] this is so bad
i don't know because people are gonna
say oh what about brig release or what
about [ __ ] uh goats or no this is so
bad and all of those problems with
overwatch were only the tip of
blizzard's mounting issues there was the
highly controversial ban of blitzchang a
hearthstone player who voiced his
support for the hong kong protesters
during an official blizzard stream
activision blizzard it has suspended a
gamer and taken his prize money away
because he made
comments supporting hong kong protesters
then there was the disaster that was
warcraft 3 reforged the game looked
sounded and handled worse than its older
predecessor blizzard's famous commitment
to quality was nowhere to be found and
competitively a match between thor zane
and moon at dreamhack anaheim 2020 had
to be restarted three times because the
game was just that broken we have no
breath of fire by the way it is drunken
haze so big miss chance on these dragon
hawks and
a disconnect
i'm gonna assume those ain't dropped but
i feel like moon was on the way to
holding this attack oh
wow
i don't need a blood mage i don't need
you
you're benched
once this
it looks like another drop
so the games went to [ __ ] overwatch
league was basically dead in the water
everybody thought that blizzard was
china's puppet
surely things couldn't get worse but as
it turned out blizzard was about to hit
a new low
on july 20th 2021 after a two-year
investigation the state of california
filed a lawsuit against activision
blizzard in this lawsuit multiple women
who either used to or still worked at
the company came forward alleging sexual
harassment abuse
discrimination unfair wages and more the
agency alleges that male employees play
video games during the work day while
delegating responsibilities to female
employees engage in sexual banter and
joke openly about rape among other
things so they're making the girls do
all the work
while they talk about rape and harassing
them many of these instances were
allegedly reported to supervisors and
higher-ups at the company and yet no
action was taken to say that the gaming
community was appalled and outraged
would be a huge understatement since
i've been employed at blizzard i've been
subjected to rude comments about my body
unwanted sexual advances
inappropriately touched
subjected to alcohol infused team events
and cube crawls
invited to have casual sex with my
supervisors and surrounded by a frat boy
culture that's detrimental to women
one person who is named in this suit is
alex afrasiyabi former senior creative
director for world of warcraft who was
permitted to engage in blatant sexual
harassment with little to no
repercussions he was so known to engage
in harassment of females that his sweet
was nicknamed the cosby sweet after
alleged rapist bill cosby how does a
nickname like that come about
a nickname that
everybody knows about
and the guy remains employed needless to
say internally activision blizzard had
some serious changes they needed to make
but rather than a total overhaul of a
deeply flawed company culture they
simply opted for a change in ownership
microsoft bought out blizzard slash
activision honestly this is like some
like disney level entertainment monopoly
type [ __ ] it's reported that the
acquisition was for 70
billion dollars you're basically
comparing a known negative thing right
which is like blizzard activision owned
by bobby kodick the [ __ ] worst guy in
the world is on epstein's black book and
you know they fire people and they're
drinking their breast milk and so it's
like
we know
we know what that is you know what i
mean like we know what that is and so
now we're going into like completely
unknown while it might seem that a tech
monolith like microsoft would swoop in
and restore order they're leaving things
the same for now the people most
responsible for the alleged behavior at
activision blizzard are still going to
be in charge for the foreseeable future
on top of that microsoft doesn't exactly
have the best track record when it comes
to absorbing other companies and making
them work
let's not forget what happened to mixer
look none of us know how this deal is
actually going to work out in the end
but in the meantime belief in blizzard's
integrity continues to sink amidst
public scrutiny and ridicule it's really
sad to see leadership kind of mishandle
these situations over and over again so
i think a lot of people are just tired
in that regard too
you know i just feel like when the news
of the lawsuit broke i just kind of
relived all of that at once like i feel
like it just kind of like i just got so
angry like wow i lived through all of
this and here are the leaders at my
company that i'm working for now saying
that this doesn't happen here because i
know it does you know so then i was just
like that's unacceptable and we should
tr we should own it and try to do better
that's what taking accountability and
leading responsibly is
there's no doubt that the old blizzard
is dead and it's never coming back but
where does that leave us going forward
all of this is awful to hear about and
it's completely normal to feel hurt and
betrayed and disgusted especially from a
company like blizzard that many people
still idolized and aspired to it's hard
to stomach continuing to give them a sub
fee or publicity uh when they've let
this happen especially considering their
responses on the other hand i'm not
convinced right now that boycotting
blizzard is going to be a direct help to
the women that work there
for one because a lot of those women
still work there and have worked very
hard on these properties
i look at blizzard
like a
dearly loved relative that is going
through a very dark time and you can't
uh you can't accept and condone some of
the things they do but deep down you
still love them because they're family
and you you wish the best for them and
you'll be there to help them out if they
let you you know and so that's that's
kind of how i view the whole thing at
the end of the day blizzard isn't just
inept leadership and allegedly horrible
internal behavior it's a company that
has been vastly important to gaming as a
whole and that continues to employ
thousands of people who are passionate
about what they do blizzard gave us more
than just their games they helped us
form some of our most precious childhood
memories unfortunately despite all the
love and respect it once commanded
blizzard is now also a glaring example
of just how far even our most revered
idols can fall
[Music]
you